Major breaking news as the Firearms
Policy Coalition has just launched a
major attack on New York that is defined
as a quote unquote sensitive place, i.e.
a governmentmandated gun-free zone all
of Time Square. This of course occurred
after Broom was decided in 2022 and the
fires policy coalition has just launched
an attack to knock it out. Watch out.
This is may very well be destined for
the US Supreme Court. We're going to
break it down when we come right back.
Hey folks, I'm Mark Smith, host of the
Forbox Donner, proud American gun owner,
constitutional attorney, member of the
United States Supreme Court Barn, and
proud to say the top voice of the Second
Amendment in America. Thank you. 2025
and 2026 guns awards. All right. So,
major lawsuit has just been commenced
against the state of New York and
Leticia James
over New York's banning of guns in the
entire area of Times Square, which is a
large swath of Midtown Manhattan.
This, of course, was defined as a
sensitive place, which is a euphemism
for a governmentmandated gun-free zone.
Of course, we know the criminals don't
pay any attention to these laws and it
turns into a killing zone because all
the law-abiding ordinary Americans are
defenseless at the hands of scumbags.
So, in a huge lawsuit brought by Yehuda
Goldberger and the Firearms Policy
Coalition against Leticia James, you
know Leticia James and uh several other
New York officials including Alvin
Bragg.
Second amendment challenge here arguing
that the banning of guns in Times Square
violates the Second Amendment for among
other reasons that does not allow for
proper security. Meaning it anyone can
walk in there and if anyone including
criminals can just jolly old walk into
an area. It by definition cannot be a
sensitive place. It cannot be a
sensitive place consistent with the
second amendment. Nor is it consistent
with the history of sensitive places i.e
government mandated gunfree zones going
back to the founding and the creation of
our constitution in 1791. The second
amendment is 1791. The constitution
itself was created a few years earlier
than that. So with that said, here's how
this lawsuit starts off right at the
top. Yehuda Goldberger and firearms
policy coalition buy and through council
bring this complaint against defendants,
New York City officials responsible for
administering and enforcing the state's
laws and regulations governing carriage
of firearms in public and time square.
The Constitution guarantees the right of
the people to keep and bear arms when
the people enshrined in their governing
charter the right to carry weapons in
case of confrontation. They did not
leave the freedom to exercise that right
at the mercy of very government
officials whose hands they sought to
bind. Instead, the right to keep
environments ranks among the most
fundamental rights necessary to our
system of ordered liberty. And the
Second Amendment demands that certain
policy choices are definitely off the
table. That's exactly right, folks.
Basically, Breuan said unequivocally
that the text of the constitution, the
text of the second amendment, the right
of people to keep, which means to
possess, the right of the people to
bear, which means to carry in public for
self-defense, among other things, uh, is
protected by the text of the second
amendment. And that is what the Supreme
Court said. That's what the Second
Amendment's text says. With that said,
as we know, in 2022, the Supreme Court
decided the Breuan case, and shortly
thereafter, New York State called an
emergency session. Kathy Hokll, that
embarrassing governor that wants to
bring rich people back to New York,
which ain't going to happen. As you saw
her statements this week, she can't
believe that they're broke now that they
drove all productive people out of New
York by and large. Not all of them, but
a lot of them. A lot of the rich ones,
of course, went to Florida and Texas or
whatever. One of that same Governor
Kathy Hokll says we want to go back to
musketss. That's the world she wants to
live in. I'm sure that doesn't apply to
her personal uh security guards to
protect her home. Nevertheless, uh that
she created an emergency session after
brewing and had the New York State
legislature pass all these sensitive
place laws that basically said that even
even though you get a carry license in
New York, there's basically nowhere you
can carry the gun because they've
defined everything as a euphemism
euphemistically a sensitive place, which
means government mandated gun-free zone,
which is exactly what I predicted the
anti-gunners were going to do months
before the Bruin decision was decided.
Those of you who've been with the four
box of Diner channel from the start, you
remember that prediction that I made way
before June of 2022, the day that the
Supreme Court issued brewing. With that
said, here's what this uh complaint has
to say attacking the sensitive place
notion of Times Square. Check it out. On
June 23rd, 2023, the United States
Supreme Court held in Nura versus Breuan
consistent with Heler and McDonald that
the Second and 14th Amendments protects
an individual's right to carry a handgun
for self-defense outside the home and
accordingly declared New York's proper
cause discretionary carry licensing
scheme unconstitutional.
Just over a week later, on July 1st,
2022,
New York enacted sweeping new firearms
restrictions to supplant those that the
Supreme Court had invalidated. Those
restrictions effectively nullify
Brewan's acknowledgement of a right to
carry guns in public by declaring many
public places quote unquote sensitive
locations sensitive locations where the
carrying of firearms is unlawful even
for individuals who are licensed
consistent with state law. As relevant
to this case, New York banned carrying
firearms in the area commonly known as
Times Square. That's right. So they
labeled a lot of places sensitive. They
said you can't bring a gun here even if
you have a license. The problem is, for
those of you who know New York City, you
already know this, uh, but Times Square
is really in the center of Manhattan.
The main burl, New York City has five
burls. The main one that really matters
is Manhattan. Um, in the center of
Manhattan, you have Time Square. So,
even if you don't live in Times Square,
you don't work in Times Square, you
often travel through Time Square. So, if
you're trying to bring your handgun from
the west side highway, let's say, over
to the east side, u you got to in many
instances, if if you're in Midtown, of
course, you have to cross through Time
Square. And that would be a crime, a
felony. And that means even if you don't
have to go to Times Square, you just
pass through, you can't legally do it in
violation of the Second Amendment. And
that is exactly what this complaint has
to say. They point this out as follows.
The Times Square carry ban unlawfully
deprivives individuals of the right to
keep and bear arms in what is
indisputably a public place where the
need for self-defense may arise. This
makes a mockery of the Supreme Court's
holding in Bruin, which reaffirmed that
personal security extends to more than
just those who work in marbled halls
guarded constantly by a vigilant and
dedicated police force. Ciden Clarence
Thomas by the way. What is more, the
Supreme Court in Breuan addressed the
very justifications New York relies on
in an attempt to support the Times
Square uh Times Square carry ban. In the
Supreme Court's discussion of the
historical limits it identified on the
right, the court rejected the idea the
historical locational restrictions could
be relied on to justify broadly limiting
carry in New York City, explaining that
there is no historical basis for New
York to effectively declare the island
of Manhattan a sensitive place simply
because a crowded and protected
generally by the New York City Police
Department. While not designating the
entire island a sensitive place, New
York has done the next worst thing and
declared a large portion and central
through fair of New York City a
sensitive place based on that same
rejected reasoning. Those are all good
observations. And again, as we've talked
about, the way to figure out what is a
sensitive place is you have to look at
what the Supreme Court has said about
specific sensitive places as they see it
and then draw analogies. Specifically in
Nura versus Bruin, the Supreme Court
said that the three specific areas at
the time of the founding in 1791 when
the second amendment was adopted were
legislative chambers, i.e. the halls of
Congress, let's say, or the state house,
courouses and polling places. Now, as to
polling places, do not make this
mistake. Let me be very, very, very
clear here. When the Supreme Court
referred to polling places, it was
talking about polling places in 1791
was where no where gun-free zones in
many instances and protected by
security. When the Supreme Court refers
to legislative chambers, courouses, and
polling places in the Brewan decision,
it is talking about those places that
the government could ban guns as a
general matter at the founding.
Do not confuse that with you can ban
guns today in the 21st century at
polling places simply because that was
doable in 1791. And among other reasons,
among other reasons,
at the time of the founding, when you
went to the polls to vote, listen very
carefully. It's extremely important to
be the smartest person in the room to
get this right. In America, when you
went to vote at the time of the
founding, you went to the polling places
in 1791 and the early early America,
early American period there, right?
your vote was made public. You had to
publicly declare your votes.
It was only in the late 19th century
after the civil war almost into the 20th
century do you have the rise of the
Australian ballot which is the
confidential secret ballot that you go
into a little place and you vote and
even your spouses don't know who you're
voting for because you vote by yourself.
That is a different development and that
I think in part explains that at the
time of the founding there was security
and now perhaps there's not really any
security at these polling places and
thus in my view under the second
amendment you cannot ban guns there if
you don't have security which gives rise
to what exactly was the common
denominator the characteristic that you
could see in founding era polling places
founding era courouses
founding era legislative chambers. What
tied those things together? What was the
common denominator that made them
sensitive places? It wasn't simply a
label that guns were not allowed. No, it
was that government provided security at
those locations.
So, not only could you not bring a gun
in, but the bad guys could not bring a
gun in and there was armed security
provided by the government to protect
the people that attended.
For example, the judiciary judiciary act
of 1789
which created the federal court system
is a great example that says I see it.
Remember the Supreme Court is created by
article three of the constitution.
Article 3 of the Constitution creates
the Supreme Court and the inferior
courts that Congress thereby creates. In
the Judiciary Act of 18, I'm sorry, of
1789,
Congress passed the Judiciary Act and
created the inferior court system that
was below the US Supreme Court. And what
did that Congress do at the same time
they created the judiciary, the court
system under the Supreme Court? They
also created the United States Marshall
Service.
And what was the job of the Marshall
Service when it was created along with
the federal court system in 1789? That
would be to protect the courts.
The point is that at the time of the
founding, courts were protected by
baiffs and marshals.
Polling places were protected by
sheriffs and deputy sheriffs and the
like. sheriff deputies and all sorts of
pe folks like this
and legislative chambers were protected
by a sergeant of arms sergeant-at-arms
and people along those lines.
Therefore, when you look at that history
under Breuan,
remember the government bears the burden
to show there's a historical tradition
of firearms and regulation that would
justify, for example, banning guns in
Time Square, which is this huge swath of
public property generally protected by
NYPD. But the Supreme Court said in Brun
that was not enough to make something a
quote unquote sensitive place. There has
to be at a minimum comprehensive
security, i.e. limited points of entry,
metal detectors to make sure that people
cannot sneak in weapons, and armed
security. We see this at TSA.
Armed security is a TSA. Meet detectors
are TSA. Limited points of entry are
TSA. We see this when you go into the
United States Department of Justice
building into the US capital, into the
Supreme Court, into all the courts. We
know what this comprehensive security
means. It means limited points of entry.
Those points of entry are guarded with
metal detectors so people cannot get
guns in. And you have armed security
willing to step up and use those weapons
to defend the people that are in that
location.
At a minimum, none of these
characteristics exist when it comes to
Times Square in the 21st century. Again,
you look at the se 18th century, you
look at what these three examples
illustrate. They illustrate that in all
instances there is some sort of enhanced
security provided for by the government
and that in part is necessary for it to
be a comprehensive a sensitive place
secured and if you do not have that
comprehensive security it means among
other things the government clearly
doesn't think it's sensitive because
they're not treating such they're not
acting out they may labeling it is not
the same you know the old saying actions
speak louder than words well if you say
a place is super sensitive you can't
have guns there then the government
actually has to do something about it
they can't just label They have to show
and demonstrate through actions they
really care about it. If they don't,
again, it's not really a sensitive
place. It's just too it's designed
specifically to undercut Second
Amendment rights. And that is a point
that's essentially made in this
complaint um cited to a handsome
YouTuber with wonderful hair that you
all know and love. Uh let's check out
what they have to say in this complaint
about the notion of enhanced security in
sensitive places and how that all works
together in the modern world based upon
the history of the United States going
back to the 18th century our founding.
Check it out. The Times Square carry ban
is utterly incompatible with the Second
Amendment's text and cannot be justified
as consistent with the nation's
historical tradition of firearms
regulation. The historical principle
uniting the places that Brewan assumed
were sensitive at the founding
courouses, legislatores, and polling
places was the presence of security that
actually functioned to prevent
individuals from carrying firearms. No
place where legislators banned firearms
contemporaneous with their founding lack
such security and where they wanted to
protect a location and could not provide
security. Their solution was not to
erect a useless paper barrier or metal
sign that would never stop an armed
criminal intent on violence, but rather
but rather to oblige law- abiding
citizens to carry firearms for
everyone's protection. What is more, the
wellestablished limit at the founding
was in places of public congregation
such as Times Square to bar only carry
with the intent to terrify with the
intent to terrify. And of course, this
uh this section quotes W. Smith,
enlightenment thinker Caesar Vicary and
his influence on the founders. My law
reviewview article in the Pepperdine law
review back a few years ago. So there
you have it. It's a very exciting
lawsuit. I think it has real potential
to go to the Supreme Court because it
really does illustrate that what Bruins
said about just because a place has
people there congregating about and you
have presumptively law enforcement
floating around, that is not enough to
be a quote unquote sensitive place
consistent with Brun where you can ban
guns. Right? That's why they said
Manhattan could not be defined as a
sensitive place. In the Brewing
decision, by analogy here, Times Square
is essentially Manhattan where you got a
lot of people floating around. Cops are
generally around, but that is simply not
enough to be a governmentmandated
gun-free zone, consistent with the
Second Amendment, and it is thereby
verboten. So, we'll see what the New
York federal courts have to do with this
case. Uh, but at least the ball is
rolling and of course we will keep you
apprised as developments occur in this
major federal lawsuit. Again, just among
others, Leticia James. All right, folks.
There you have it. Hope you enjoyed
today's episode. Make sure you follow me
over there on X4boxes. Don't forget to
subscribe both YouTube and the Rumble
and I'll talk to you again real soon
here at the Forboxes Diner.
>> Orders up. Table 2A.